let's say that we've got the function f
of X and it is equal to the natural log
of X plus 5 over X minus 1 and what we
want to figure out is what is f prime of
X and I encourage you to pause this
video and try to figure it out on your
own so there's two ways that you could
approach this I would call one way the
easy way and the other way the hard way
and we'll work through both of them the
easy way is to recognize your logarithm
properties to remember that the natural
log of a over B remember natural log is
just log base the number E so this is
just going to be equal to the natural
log of a minus the natural log of B so
if we just apply this property right
over here to simplify this expression or
at least simplify it from a point of
view in terms of having to take its
derivative we can rewrite f of X we can
write f of X as being equal to the
natural log of x plus 5 minus the
natural log of X minus 1 and when we
take the derivative now with respect to
X F prime of X well this is going to be
the derivative of the natural log of X
plus 5 with respect to X plus 5 so
that's going to be 1 over X plus 5 times
the derivative of X plus 5 with respect
to X I'm just applying the chain rule
here and that's just going to be 1 so
this the derivative of that is that and
the derivative of this well let's see
we're going to have a minus sign there
and the derivative of natural log of X
minus 1 with respect to X minus 1 is
going to be 1 over X minus 1 and then
the derivative of x minus 1 with respect
to X is just 1 so you just multiply this
by 1 doesn't really change the value and
we're done we were able to figure out
the derivative of F now what's the hard
way you might be thinking or maybe you
did do it when you try to approach it on
your own well that's not to simplify
this expression using this property and
just to try to power through this using
the chain rule
so let's try to do that so in that case
f prime of x it's going to be the
derivative of this whole thing with
respect to X plus five over X minus one
which is going to be 1 over X plus 5
over X minus 1 times the derivative
times the derivative with respect to X
of X plus 5 over X minus 1 this is just
the chain rule derivative of this whole
thing with respect to this expression
times the derivative of this expression
with respect to X just the chain rule so
let's see this is going to be equal to
let me use some colors here what this
one I'm boxing off in blue that's the
same thing as X minus 1 over X plus 5
I'm just taking the reciprocal of this
and then it's going to be x and then
I'll do this in magenta
that's not magenta so that's going to be
x and I'm going to rewrite it as the
derivative with respect to X of X plus 5
times X minus 1 to the negative 1 power
and I like to write it that way because
I always forget I always forget the
whole quotient rule thing but I remember
the product rule so this thing so let me
just rewrite it then I think you already
appreciate why this is the hard way so
let me write this this is X minus 1 over
X plus 5 times so let's apply the
product rule derivative of x plus 5 well
that's just 1 times the second term
times X minus 1 to the negative 1 so
that's 1 over X minus 1 and then plus
what's the derivative of X minus 1 to
the negative 1 well let's see that's
going to be that's going to be negative
X minus 1 to the negative 2 power so I
could say negative 1 X minus 1 to the
negative 2 or I could just write it like
this and then times the derivative of X
minus 1 with respect to X well that's
just going to be 1 and then times this X
plus 5 so actually so x times X
plus five so all I did here product rule
derivative derivative of this is one
times that and that gave us that right
over there and then I took the
derivative of this which is this right
over here negative one over X minus one
of the over X minus one squared or you
could say negative X minus one of the
negative two power times this first
expression right over there
so that's that derivative and now let's
see if we can simplify things so if we
let's see if we were to if we were don't
let me just rewrite everything so this
is equal to X minus one over X plus five
times one over X minus one minus X plus
five over X minus one squared now let's
think about what happens when we
distribute this so when you when you
distribute this times that this
numerator cancels with that denominator
and so we're going to get we're going to
get let's see 1 over X plus five and
then when you distribute it over here
the X plus 5 is going to cancel with the
X plus 5 and one of the X minus ones is
going to cancel one of these X minus
ones you're going to be left with just
one of those X minus ones in the
denominator and so you get F prime of X
is equal to this and lucky for us we got
the same answer either way but as we see
the easy way was much easier than the
hard way